i was told that the kkk was gonna get me
and that's frightening when you're a
child
[Music]
chief marketing officer to vice
president of global brand an almost
three decade career at nike that's right
yeah you know nike was really the only
brand that was putting people of color
in their communication that showed me
you could make a living doing what you
love
why is the air force one shoe an example
of nike not chasing cool it wasn't
created to make a statement in culture
it was created to make a statement on
the court and the fact that moses malone
won on the court in the air force one
that's cool
your authenticity is your cultural
currency the minute your audience can no
longer see your original pursuit they
partner with someone else
april 2021 significant month for you in
your life i got a dm through 23andme and
that opened up meeting my birth families
the last thing you'd want to be is
rejected and it was just
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
direva ceo usa edition i hope nobody's
listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
[Music]
greg
i'm a tremendous believer in
the fact that our early years are
incredibly formative what are the things
that really left a
remaining mark on you in terms of their
influence as an experience or an event
or trauma
yes again i had two passions growing up
sport and art
and really
why i got involved in art and art of all
sorts whether it was drawing painting
sculpting
is growing up as a half black half white
adopted kid into a white family going to
a all-white school system and
experiencing uh lots of adversity
through racism and and other things art
was the thing that i was ex able to
essentially escape from reality
and find myself in
in the art and that's when i started to
discover that i could draw things in
accurate detail you know i could dream
and then put that on paper and it was
very powerful and it was a way for me to
you know not only feel empowered
but also
um engage my imagination and then sport
as well you know sport evens the playing
field if you will and so that was
essentially the other escape where i
felt like i wasn't such an outsider on
that
and so i think when you experience uh
adversity like that when you're
oftentimes the only one in the room um
which i think you can relate to even
even today
um you also look out for other outsiders
you know you're keeping an eye on other
groups or other individuals that haven't
been invited
if you will
and so you're right i took those uh
experiences uh because they never leave
you no matter how much success you have
um you carry some of those chips on your
shoulder but it doesn't have to be used
as a negative
uh and so as i made my way through life
and found myself into in positions
of influence i looked out for those
individuals on that because again when
when i grew up in the the late 70s and
early 80s
you were taught to not see color
right that was that period of time which
means how can you be empathetic if your
parents or those that are there to
support you teachers aren't seeing how
what your experience is like
so
i love today where that is not the case
and you do need to see people for how
they identify themselves to better equip
and empower them to achieve you know
their hopes and dreams
when you're young and you're different
in some way we can all probably relate
to being different in some way when
we're younger
but not everybody can relate to what it
feels like to be racially abused when
you're young
and the confusion the
you know the inadequacy whatever it
might be that that leaves you with
can you recall the first time someone
racially abused you when you were
younger
absolutely
i was actually in kindergarten and it
started happening every day i was told
that the kkk was going to get me
now i didn't know what the ku klux klan
the kkk was but i did know that i was
the only person that they were saying it
to and then you'd come into school the
next day and you'd hear this the kkk is
going to get you
and that's quite
frightening when you're a child right um
and um you're you're in that situation
alone and you you don't necessarily
have the individuals that you could talk
to about it so essentially you kind of
you you bottle that up and
that was the first situation and the
issue
oftentimes with with kids certainly at
you know
during that particular time
is you identify people through their
appearance right
on that
and for me i just hadn't developed the
voice to fight with my voice so
obviously it resulted in a lot of
altercations throughout my early life
and even into my teenage life because it
took me a while to develop
a voice to be able to combat that with
words right
so that was the beginning but it didn't
take long to uh start hearing the n-word
shortly thereafter
in high school
uh in grade school in grade school and
so again though i i share those moments
more as a way of of telling people that
you know make sure you're looking beyond
what's on the surface
this is
gets back to great brand building
don't just look at the assumptions and
observations that we all see
you got to look beyond that to see how
people really are experiencing and
feeling within their life and you you
saw that come to life in some of the
campaigns that i worked on right
stand up speak up campaign with tyrion
re
was all about fighting racism that you
act that's invisible you can't see it
but the players are hearing it
i want this to be uplifting
but i think it's important to your point
to understand where we come from
and our adversity doesn't need to
necessarily be something that holds us
back it can be fuel
for the way we are motivated
to get to those points where we're we're
putting work out in the world or helping
others so that they don't have to go
through that
you reference your art in the book as
being a bit of an escape for you in the
early years
what was your art what was it was it
design was it photography what was your
art my parents didn't have much um but
um i they really invested in my passion
for for art and design
and i shared a bedroom with
my two brothers small bedroom and so
imagine three beds
and then there were three other
elements in this bedroom okay one was my
drafting table and desk where i drew
all the time second was a sand filled
weightlifting set that just sat in the
middle and then finally my parents
which is um pretty innovative they just
basically left a wall white and they put
a wood frame
around the entire wall and they said
this is your mural and you can paint or
draw anything you want on it
right and again cramped space i just
want you to think about like three kids
in here so i would draw sports logos
baseball football hockey logos on this
this is one of my obsession with
branding um and the art of how powerful
and and how
logos and symbols can connect and create
so much story and emotion and then the
other thing i drew all the time was
superheroes because i was obsessed with
comic books and that idea of
heroics and athleticism but within that
i i started to understand how your art
can
communicate and through those logos and
the visual communication that
i saw
within the world of sports
started to pique my interest
in in doing this
and i'll take it a step further
i got really lucky uh when i was
15 i got a job in a warehouse at a small
publishing company
just in the warehouse after school and
throughout the summer just packing books
into boxes but i noticed that there was
an art department
in this place
and i'm not sure where i got the courage
but somehow i did i went in and i i said
hey is it possible for me to spend part
of the time in this art department and
part of it in the warehouse
you have you have to put yourself out
there to ask i learned that at that
point and they said yes
and so suddenly i was shoulder to
shoulder as a 15 year old with
art directors and writers and creative
directors and storytellers and then by
the next year i spent
all my time in the art department and
not only in there doing menial tasks
they were having me do illustrations
they were having me do page layouts
again this is pre-computer
so um that showed me at an early age
that you could make a living
doing what you love what are you
passionate about because up until that
point i wasn't necessarily sure
how you could
essentially
you know make a living doing that so
that that was kind of my earliest stage
in terms of art as commerce if you will
was within the publishing arena but what
it did do is it gave me a shortcut to to
start to focus on that so by the time i
got to college i knew
that
i wanted to be a designer
you knew you wanted to be a designer
that's right yeah and you went on and
studied design
at college graduated
and then
the story as i as i heard it is you
basically get two internships
post-graduation you get a call from nike
nike said that they've got this urgent
position you've got to drop everything
and come now and start at nike and that
starts and i've skipped a process there
but yeah that starts the
an almost three decade career at nike
that's right yeah where you move from
what was your first role at nike called
do you remember just a graphic design
intern
graphic design intern
to
chief marketing officer to vice
president of global brand innovation
over almost 30 years
for me this is remarkable for many
reasons obviously being involved nike is
one of those companies and culture and
in society that is more than a brand
they're more than a shoe company for
many reasons which we'll talk about but
also the really staggering thing is you
stayed at a company for 30 almost 30
years
my question there is
what is it about you that made you so
loyal to that company
because a lot of people can love their
job but they still get that desire to
move on and do something awesome
30 years at one company what is it about
you
that made you stay in terms of your
character or whatever
yeah i think two two things one is the
again this this incredible situation
where
art and sport
uh came together
and this brand certainly mastered the
art of art of marketing right
and and expressing the art that exists
in sport and the art of storytelling so
i didn't have to choose it's like wow
you show up to this place and it's like
your two passions on full display
that's number one
two it's i often times told people that
nike was like
miniature graduate schools because every
two years there was either a world cup
or a summer olympics so imagine the
transformation in terms of innovation in
terms of new athletes in terms of new
platforms and technology in terms of how
you can engage with consumers and so not
to mention what your audience is
experiencing during that time in terms
of how they want to engage with brands
and so i always told people it's almost
like the
it was a new slightly new company every
two years and
to be able to participate in both these
these you know essentially restarts or
revolutions right so that was very
exciting then i'd say the final thing
um is that you know by the time i was a
teenager and started to see seeing
nike's commercials you know nike was
really the only brand that was
putting people of color
in their communication really you had to
look really hard
around the arena of of companies to see
anyone else doing that and so
that started to instill in me the power
that this brand has um to represent uh
everyone but and also you know it's in
their mission statement to bring
inspiration and innovation to every
athlete
so um those are some of the factors that
um
uh kept me
engaged for for that long as well as um
i i have this you know nike's
original um
slogan was there is no finish line
before just do it there is no finish
line
and so if
you're you know maybe a perfectionist or
you're always in pursuit of better
and even to your own detriment sometimes
right never satisfied never finished i
was kind of all of those things
oftentimes i think a lot of creators and
makers are right so that was the other
part of it that you could always keep
reaching um for that next
design or that next story
and um and the company's expectations
were just as high of you as itself
you know
um and what what's great about
nike and certainly the nike i grew up
with is
complacency was the enemy of creativity
so there was no
sitting back right it's kind of that
forward lean just like in in athletics
so that's just a a few of the um
aspects i think that um
just you know created that
longevity and loyalty
brands companies teams they
over time learn what's making them
successful and lean further and further
into that so i'm wondering in your 30
years at nike what did you see nike
realize while you were there and lean
more into in terms of the values of the
organization how it operates from a
marketing perspective a culture
perspective or whatever do you
understand what i'm trying to say like
sure well first and foremost i think and
i you know
i i'm a brand advisor now with
establishments brands and startups
and
you know
what nike had from the beginning is such
a clear
brand house if you will
its belief its mission its vision its
values you know where are you going how
are you gonna get there
what do you believe what's your promise
to your audience and what are the
characteristics and traits that compose
your brand in that pursuit um to deliver
inspiration and innovation to everyone
and so it's imagine the power of that in
terms of everyone is clear as they walk
through the door
to show up to work why they're there and
i say this because a lot of brands can't
say that
a lot of startups haven't even got there
yet because they're just trying to
perfect their product and get it to
market
and so first and foremost this idea that
authenticity and serving the athlete
is
the anchor
at all times
so even though you're trying to be maybe
the most influential and coolest brand
on earth you know and there's an art to
doing that
um you always have to go back and ensure
that um it serves the athlete in the the
deepest way possible and that's why you
know
maybe we'll get to this later but
um i always use that mantra don't chase
cool
because uh most likely you're not gonna
catch it
and that idea that your your
authenticity in terms of what i've
learned over and over again keep going
back to your authenticity is your
cultural currency the minute your
audience can no longer see your original
pursuit
and every company is a bit different
is the day they kind of leave you and go
go engage and partner with someone else
that's in part because you've left
yourself right in the pursuit of cool
you've abandoned your authenticity you
talk about that in chapter six of your
book emotion by design which is out now
you talk about the air force one
in that chapter as an example of
success in that realm so
why is the air force one shoe an example
of nike not chasing cool
well first and foremost uh it's an
innovation that was created in 1982
that
was
created to serve the basketball athlete
right it wasn't created to make a
statement in culture it was created to
make a statement on the court
and the designer was obsessed with
creating something that gave that
athlete an advantage
and it's really hard to create if you
want any chance for a product to
ultimately become a cultural icon if you
will and by the way brands don't get to
decide that you know your audience does
over time
then you must the the the inception and
creation of that product has to start
with
what's the benefit that you're trying to
deliver what's the problem you're trying
to solve
so that's that's part one and the fact
that someone like moses malone who was a
center for the philadelphia 76ers at the
time you know won on the court
in the air force one so that's cool
that's proving that innovation
right out of the gates and so from there
as it grew in stature
what was great about all the teams that
played a role across all the different
disciplines at nike to bring this to
market every year
is all of the storytelling was rooted in
authenticity this colorway came from
this basketball court
this colorway was from this
new york outdoor court
and this player scored x amount of
points you know the stories are rooted
in an emotion like and you as a
enthusiast for this sneaker got to take
part in a little bit of that and as i
talk about in the book you know at some
point stories no longer
you know belong only to the brand they
get passed down um and so um the air
force one is interesting because this
year again it was the the highest
selling sneaker
out there
and so it's very accessible and yet it's
also you could argue the most um
culturally relevant sneaker as well and
so it's aspirational
and so my point is that's by design
you're you're ensuring that there's a
level of the authentic storytelling
and that those that you're partnering
with the ambassadors if you will that
show up in your communication um on that
have a have a a real
um connection and affinity
for the air force one just like kendrick
lamar grew up with the nike cortez
sneaker
very real relationship with the shoe
that's very much a part of la
and so when we partnered with kendrick
lamar it's coming from a shared passion
and that authenticity comes through
to your your audience right when it
doesn't that's when it it feels like
you're chasing cool
um and so i always say just make sure
your connections are are really really
clear to your audience in terms of who
you partner with what is the the real
purpose of your product
beyond all the the shiny new
um partnerships and other things you can
do
you still have to kind of go back to its
its roots
an example of where a brand has
has not done that well
can you think of a couple top of them
well for some reason i thought of that
uh that pepsi advert i know it was a
tragedy for so many reasons but when
they got one of those kardashians to
kind of hold the pepsi can in that
social justice scene that riot scene you
couldn't as an audience member
understand why that kardashian was stood
there apparently as the
cure to a social justice issue holding a
kind of it all felt and disjointed
inauthentic yeah because you have to be
able to connect what you sell to what
the world needs in a specific moment
when it comes to
social impact or social justice so
whether you're a food and beverage
company an automobile company a sneaker
company
if
you want to
participate in that conversation and you
know break down barriers and empower
people or change the way people feel
about a particular issue
it's for nike you had to speak through
the lens of sport
that's the connection right and i think
when you see a brand maybe miss you know
sometimes you might be
watching tv and you'll see an ad and
it's clear that this whoever this brand
is that they are trying to
create positive change in the world but
you can't figure it out and it's not
until the end that you see the logo
you're like okay i don't get the
connection
and so the point is is like you you have
to start by saying
um
is what's happening in this situation
uh relate to our values and our mission
and then if it does
what new unique insight are we bringing
to the conversation that's not already
being talked about and then finally the
the other thing steven is is um
because i think sometimes the default is
we need to say something as a brand when
there are so many other ways that you
can engage
and and be a part of the conversation
right and um
just just look at what epic games did in
terms of taking the uh revenue from
fortnite
over a period of time
and making donations to ukraine relief
they didn't do an ad
but they found a way that was authentic
to them
to
you know create an opportunity that's
going to help a lot of people um in a
really tough situation right now so
that's the thing when i'm talking to to
brands it's like that's just number one
it's like storytelling isn't always
um the example advertising in terms of
you know social impact statements um and
um part one and part two you you must
um ensure
that
what you want to say
clearly comes through
who you are as a brand and what you
bring into the world that's why i say
connect what you sell with what the
world needs if you can't do that then
most likely you need to think about kind
of moving into a different arena so
those are when when i see something
maybe that's tone deaf or it's not um
you know it's usually because it's just
simply not on brand
and it's confusing to your audience
much of the the things we'll talk about
i'm sure are underpinned by a topic you
talk about in the t and in the book in
chapter two which is teams and culture
um that kind of underpins everything you
referenced how when people walk in the
door at nike it's quite clear that
there's a they have clarity of culture
in terms of why they're there and what
what they're doing there etc
you were at nike for almost 30 years um
had a lot of people work underneath you
um you observe that organization from
various perspectives
how does one build a culture that wins
on its objective
and how do they and how does someone
keep that culture and police it and
protect it from
scale and you know harm and you know
yeah no it's it's a it's a great great
point um because you know creative
collaboration
uh is unique because oftentimes
uh creativity and innovation is a very
personal pursuit right it can get pretty
territorial you know you've spent a lot
of time on this and
you know you're you you want insurance
essentially that you you get credit and
so a lot of what you're doing is trying
to instill both self-confidence and
self-awareness
um so that and you're trying to
eliminate kind of the silos and in
independent kind of
studios you if you will um i was given
this awesome opportunity to run all the
creative functions at nike you know
here's the coolest
most influential brand and so my job was
to take
advertising and digital marketing and
brand design and event marketing
take all these groups that have worked
independently for quite some time
where the
integration took a lot of work with
really long passes and i i used this
example frequently and i'm sure it drove
my my teams crazy but
i used uh fc barcelona as an example of
radical creative collaboration you know
their style of play the tiki taka it's
all those short passes there's there's
no waiting everybody's moving around the
field at the same time and i would show
the team these clips of this you know
pep guardiola's fc barcelona team
passing the ball 40 50 60 times in a
game in a row without interruption okay
and how does that happen it's because
you could say radical selflessness
right the goal is just
literally the pursuit is still to put
the goal
in uh the net um you need the buy-in and
my job was to make sure that i was there
with the empathy needed to recognize the
contributions of everybody but
but to also ask people to make the
sacrifice
so that we could run faster
be more timely
create more distinctive work and
ultimately as things
are going the consumer expects
everything in their life to be connected
right the last thing they would want to
hear about is that
um there are these really long handoffs
between agencies and brands and
departments and that's why the work is
kind of disjointed you can't have that
you'll you'll lose your consumer so part
of it is it was creating this
connected team this this one team that
that operated
with great chemistry just like the the
greatest um teams in the world on that
and
maybe one other piece to that was this
this idea of individuality and so for
for that and again i'm telling you i'm
sure there's folks out there that
got tired of seeing my my um parallels
with the sport of football
but the brazil national team was a team
that i had you know this this 25-year
relationship with starting as an intern
right and what's great about the brazil
national team is that um they played
with the zhenga style which means to
sway
and zynga is is you know the influences
of that style of play
comes from capoeira you know brazilian
martial arts and samba
um
but um it emphasized uh the individual
eccentricities of the players um we've
all watched brazil over the years we've
been enthralled by them and sometimes
they drive us a bit mad because maybe
there's a bit
of disorganization but at the end of the
day they've won five world cups more
than any other team and that's because
they value the diversity and ex the the
perspective and experience and expertise
of each individual player
and so yes there's structure that team
um yes there's an expectation that
there's a level of precision but they
allow
improv they allow spontaneity to reveal
opportunity throughout those games and
that's why oftentimes anywhere you go in
the world
it's someone's second favorite team
beyond the club that they support
and so that was another point of
inspiration that i use to lead these
these massive teams right you're talking
about just the scale of of nike in terms
of the output
of of creative around the world
you needed to still have a high degree
of operational excellence to run
something
like that but i wanted to make sure that
you were incentivized to take risks
you had the space to be able to
present ideas that may not be on the
plan
and you had a receptive executive team
that was willing to hear from you
and that's why there's so many examples
of the book
um of work that wasn't briefed
of work that was just a conversation
with a couple people who were empowered
to visualize that idea
and then put it out in the world many of
them
um ideas that had great scale and are
still around today so
that's just a little insight in terms of
how i looked at building that chemistry
how did you incentivize risk
or
disincentivize risk adversion
so it's a great call and again i i'm
still figuring it out
um because
think about it you're you're asking
individuals um
right brain and left brain thinkers
to essentially
you're saying i said this often we're
going to develop four different
concepts this
quarter
and they're going to be outside of our
normal workload because again we have to
deliver the business front and center we
can't get distracted from that
but alongside of that we're gonna
visualize and prototype four ideas but
you know what only one of them
probably will have a chance so that's
not for everyone right oftentimes people
only want to work on things that have
almost 100 certainty of finding their
way in the world
you know
and
i had to condition everyone to ensure
that they were were comfortable taking
the big swings and part of that is
seeing
the end results
like again let's look at the last two
years you see this particular concept
that is now in
you know 500 stores around the world
you know it's
one example but the house of hoops
example we had a conversation about
how could we
create a store
specific to basketball
that had the same level of passion and
energy that a kid's room would have
if they loved basketball you go into a
kid's room they would have posters and
so much inspiration and objects and
pictures
that really express their passion and
yet how come you go into a store
oftentimes and
it might just be shoes on on a wall and
you're not feeling the story and the
legacy of that
and so
rendering that up and knowing that in
three days you could have an audience
with the president of the company and
not only that you could get a go no go
that quickly of well let's let's try
this concept in the wild and then lo and
behold in less than two years you have
300 of those stores
around the world so
all you need is a couple of those
examples to say okay well i'd like to
participate in that
and
i buy into this idea that not everything
we're going to do is is going to make it
but why i say that i'm still trying to
figure it out is is
it is hard to convince some people
that
failure is what leads to success
that and if i can use this example it's
not in the book but it's literally my
favorite
commercial ad of all time and it's
michael jordan's 9 000 shots
and
amazing
uh commercial from 1997 and the widening
kennedy agency sat down with him and
learned that michael had missed 9 000
shots
26 times he was asked to take the
game-winning shot
and he missed
and he said yet i failed over and over
again but that's why i succeed
and that's the spirit of
risk-taking
in the innovation space
you need you need to take the shot
because even if you miss it success will
come down the road and so that's what i
try to instill
uh with my team
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
chapter three of your book the title is
never play it safe play to win which is
very much in line with what you're
talking about there and i think one of
the more interesting concepts
which which was mentioned in the book
which i could really relate to was
how you say that some of nike's boldest
ideas
came when the team had no time
or resources
and actually that's really what founded
my company to be honest because uh we
ran out of money so all of the
conventional marketing um channels were
out of budget so we were left to figure
something else out and that's when we
started thinking about social media in
2012
and it was free we could put time in and
get a big return and off we went and
that started my company which now you
know ended up making 700 million
whatever it is this year it'll make
um and that was when we ran out of money
our best ideas came so when i read that
i thought oh this is
interesting
so so true so often uh and also i put a
yeah a timeline in a budget um or lack
of budget but a strict timeline can be
amazing right do you always do timelines
i was going to ask you that as well do
you always make sure projects have
timelines not necessarily but um but i
like to put a timeline on how quickly
you visualize a conversation
um that is i can't say this enough and
if i have one suggestion to
smaller brands or even startups as
they're starting to expand it's like
when you have a conversation like build
a either build internally or have a
relationship with an agency that can
take your conversations and the ideas
you have and quickly visualize them
in a visceral way so and you've heard it
before a picture says a thousand words
and the problem oftentimes with
businesses
that maybe
are a bit uh bureaucratic
is you and i could have a conversation
about a cool idea and then three months
go by and we see each other again it's
like you know what happened to that yeah
i don't know well no one took ownership
of it one and two
i would walk out of those conversations
over and over again
i'd walk over to the visualization team
and i said let's let's come back to the
team let's surprise them
in three days
with either an image or a short gif or a
film or even
often times
an app prototype that was working
if i didn't do that um then
more often than not you might forget
that the conversations ever happened so
i went on that tangent just to say
um i think it's incredibly effective
these brands
large and small
that have
visualization capability
um and that everyone understands why
that's a competitive advantage
um and so many of the concepts
that were brought to life in this book
um
you know came out of the speed at which
we brought the idea to life it wasn't
well our agency's too busy
so maybe
two months from now we can talk to him
about you know this this this new um nft
id we have no it's like how about start
to riff on some of those ideas
um so that you're first to play in that
in that sector
on that so i guess and maybe if i can
just you know there's one story in this
book which was the the ronaldinho one of
my favorite footballers of all time but
yeah we were launching a a new boot and
um there was no time and quite frankly
there really wasn't a budget or it
wasn't talked about right
but um
born out of this urgency
was this very
resourceful
approach to storytelling which was to
shoot ronaldinho with a video camera
essentially getting these new soccer
boots football boots on the pitch
and then proceeding to do that old game
that we all played growing up of
crossbar where you're sitting kind of
you know just under midfield and you're
trying to kick the ball and hit that top
of the crossbar only in this video
ronaldinho is able to do it you know two
three different times without the ball
hitting the ground and i'll leave it to
the audience to figure out if it was
real or not the point is is that
you know and
not only did we not have time but um
there was a young
platform that had just started to emerge
called youtube
and
yeah the team dropped this particular
video of ronaldinho uh on the platform
and um lo and behold
it becomes the first brand film to reach
a million views right and quite frankly
all because
there was no money no time
and the team had to be unbelievably
resourceful
to to create something that would make
people
want to watch and that gets back to
emotion by design i want to emphasize
this is that
i think the best brands ask the question
how do i want
this work
to make the consumer feel about
themselves
and make them feel empowered to go and
do great things does the work
kind of engage and stir emotions in that
way where people feel that they can go
out and do it or not does it create
indifference or
because like look there's and i'm not
saying
the speed at which we're having
conversations now with
between brands and audiences is in real
time and you're not going to be able to
create everything as a hit you know
there's not enough time money etc
um
but you should have someone in the room
that's representing your brand story
that's representing
um the emotional qualities that can be
released through your work because if
that person isn't in the room and it's
just someone looking at it as content
that needs to be distributed
that that's that's not very human the
stronger the emotional connections the
bigger
status your brand is going to have most
likely in culture and therefore
the more opportunities you would have to
step beyond the business to have a real
impact
in the world on on some of the most
pressing issues of our time
so i do believe there's a process to to
to achieving that to create a strong
emotional connection with someone else
i'm presuming you have to take a strong
emotional stance yourself often so i'm
just thinking about the things that have
revoked the strongest emotional
connections with anything i do the
things that i've evoked the strongest
emotional connections with this podcast
in its audience are strong emotional
stories
but that when you do that
when you avoid indifference
you are um
putting yourself in line for potential
criticism and attacks and you're going
to polarize people some people are going
to love and hate you
how important has that been for nike
and how important is it for
a person starting a podcast or a
business or leading a team or whatever
else for a brand like nike it was
you know
look at the athletes that represented
the brand um early on i mean they were
were all rebels you know within their
own sports and and so
you know this idea of def and you know
having a a maxim within the company that
was defy convention right so your your
your values kind of say it's like yeah
there are going to be things we do with
conviction that may be polarizing
but it is the deep belief we have in
those things
and as long as we always relate them
back to
sport and this this idea of of you know
serving the athlete
then
we're willing to go there um and
if we're not clearly tethered
to
you know what we say and what we do
then
we would deserve
the critique and the criticism
so i think you can for any
small or large company that's kind of
you know that's wrestling with this that
maybe wants to kind of go beyond um just
the transactions and truly move into
that arena where you really are having
real relationships with your audience
that their affinity for you comes from
the fact that
they're getting meaningful benefits
whether those are mental or physical
that are allowing them to progress in
life you know when you reach that status
i believe indifference isn't an option
right now i believe we need to look to
brands that have that level of success
and again it's not about scale because
there's plenty of small brands you know
mom and pop brands that are doing great
things
through their business to affect the
lives of people underserved communities
but again so much of what we're talking
about is authenticity even even
doing this book it's it's like well you
know how much social media should i do
and
on this platform does that seem like i'm
inauthentic and like i as so at the end
of the day um because i'm driving people
crazy with these questions
is that because i you know i'm not the
most public person right but but as long
as i speak to from the the
center uh and the anchor of
the power of creativity
in business and its ability to change
the world and make that connection clear
and then if people are pissed off about
that then then it is what it is
um but more often than not look at some
of the most successful brands and
they're they're it's it's made their own
business successful it's accelerated
their growth and so that's where i get
into this
um you know yeah our primary goal
certainly for a public company is to
drive
growth
both from a brand and business
standpoint
but more and more i believe that within
that you have to integrate this
you know being a great corporate citizen
um and using your platform to to to
you know
provide your innovation and your
inspiration to those that quite frankly
don't have the access and opportunity to
get it how do i find which story to tell
because if i'm if i'm running this
podcast and i'm thinking okay i need to
do the logo the branding i need to
position it in a way that's going to be
this is typically the way the brain
thinks it's trying it's
the outcome is success and it's trying
to figure out which story to tell to get
me to success so
how do i make this podcast successful
how do you go about knowing
where and how to find that story in your
business brand team whatever it is
um
and which one is the right one to tell
to get the outcome i'm looking for which
is success
the success to me is that it's not
overly packaged
the success to me is that
the transparency and of authenticity of
the conversations and that um there's a
rawness to it and that's
that is branding sometimes it's the the
lack of
design if you will
is the very thing that makes something
successful
versus there's there's uh
you know there's go-to
um
it's always the same questions and so
that that's the one thing i i really
appreciate about what you're doing is
this again back to this this being human
um as as a
um
being human and creating emotion
um and part of that is just due through
people can you know see themselves in
you or us um
and that the
yeah i mean that that's that's what i
say it's less about um sometimes uh
the traditional aspects of of branding
which is uh i want to make sure the
frame of every podcast has the color
gold and it must you know so and again
i'm saying this as as someone who's
oftentimes been pretty rigid in terms of
to grow some of these businesses
to own a brand color if you will
uh
and you pick your pick your favorite
brand there's a level of repetition
needed um to build that kind of equity
in a typeface in a color
in a in a logo
you need to build that brand frame
right oftentimes startups almost skip
that it's like no go back it's like
really build your brand uh identifiers
your brand elements right because that's
your picture frame and the stronger the
picture frame
the more the picture in it is going to
shine
the weaker that frame
then your the picture within it is kind
of it's it's just it's not on a on solid
ground
if that makes sense so that's why in the
book i talk about the picture in the
frame
and ensuring that the frame never
outshines the picture that's what i'm
getting at it's like
you're when you're thinking about brand
brand elements and how best to express
those through the different platforms
it's the right question but making sure
that they don't take away
from
the actual storytelling
within it which is the picture which
happens a lot for me so some things that
we do intentionally to try and
communicate the
i guess the heart of what we're doing on
this podcast for example in the branding
so one of the things is we always make
sure it feels like home
yeah so it's in whether in l.a or in
london it's actually shot in my actual
kitchen on a very similar looking table
people are actually surprised it looks
exactly the same but we always shoot it
at home because i think the
conversations we're having
are
homely ones they're the ones people have
at home they're not ones that you know
we could we could go to this in a
massive studio but it wouldn't be in
line with our values the other thing is
it's dark in here so that speaks to the
subject matter sometimes it speaks to
secrets the other thing is obviously the
title of the podcast is the diary of a
ceo and you you ask yourself what one
might keep in a diary it tends to be
things that are a little bit deeper yeah
and there's all these small things you
know we even i mean we spend many days
this week me and jack debating removing
the microphones because it kills
what the humanness of authentic
communication so we're thinking about
ways where we can have the microphones
hanging where you we can remove the
barrier and all these small things i
guess is that the frame is
when you think about brand elements
you're talking more about like colors
and things no i think that's the frame
as well you know when i walk into a
space i'm a bit obsessive compulsive
about
like design and details you know and i
walk in i look at the carpet and what
type of chairs and
um like the display case and what are
the objects you know and whether i go
into a restaurant or the hotel i stayed
in last night you know and i'm
i'm i'm soaking all that up but that
isn't the
that isn't the actual experience that
isn't the actual um story look you're
revealing the story um of this podcast
through all these elements
but but it's that's still the the story
frame and
is where i'm going and then um the
delivery of you know through your voice
and these conversations is what sits
within it but my but yes those
identifiers those brand elements um play
a huge role
because every one of them
i guess what i'm saying what i like
about when i walked in is it's like
everything was considered
it was nothing arbitrary
because what a miss
for for some
some brands large and small
when
they don't have a culture that um
cares deeply about those details
and i think the best ones do
and
certainly
when you think of some of the the the
most successful fashion brands like
you you know there's just an ethic
inside that any any detail large or
small
um will be intentional so and you know
that's does design you know emotion by
design the word design is really about
intention
be intentional
and look to reveal something about
yourself
through this round table you know with
the marble top it's like it all
communicates um
trust me i drive my my wife and my kids
absolutely mad
right because they've had to live with
this guy who's just constantly
moving stuff around and
you know is the clock is the bookcase
like you know curated perfectly are the
books in the right um so
if i have a problem it's in some some
ways that it's um uh i i've i'm
you know searching for perfection too
often
and what can happen is you start to
strip the soul and personality
out of something and it's been great
that i've had people throughout my
career to balance that that's back to
this idea of creative tension like if
there's a two startup founders you know
it's i love it when it's someone's it's
someone represents the art and someone
represents the science you know
someone's more analytical
in their decision-making process
and
others maybe a little bit more
non-linear maybe a little bit more right
brain
thinking um
and i love that tension because when you
don't have that it's like one side
starts to
kind of creep up and that's why i got
into you know i'm also the branding
instructor at the university of oregon's
graduate school of business and these
are
you know i'm in front of mainly folks
that want to become future gms
entrepreneurs product developers you
name it right
and but i'm there to say it's like
you know yes we're going to go through
how you create a brand plan and a brand
strategy we're going to do this but
you're also going to work on brand
identity
and
don't worry about if you you can't if
you don't think you're creative because
that's
i i just that kills me when i hear that
the application of creativity yes it's
oftentimes reserved for people that have
created a fluency
through experience and education whether
it's an architect
a coder etc
but
the creation that the site the inception
of an idea we can all participate in
that like the brainstorming of an idea
we can all participate because what
happens oftentimes is people say well i
can't draw i'm not creative
and it's like well that's
that's only part of the equation
you know i've i've done i don't know
hundred a couple hundred
i've led a couple hundred brainstorm
sessions over the years
big and small and i've never said at the
beginning of the brainstorm session
um i want all the non-creative people to
leave the room right now
because we're going to start to concept
and be creative no it's again it's
writing left brain thinkers working to
deliver
working together to conceive great
things
i'm really compelled by and i talk to my
team a lot about this about this and
you've mentioned it twice now this the
importance of details from your your 30
years of nike
how did you make sure teams cared about
the detail is it just continually
reminding them is there something else
we can do to make sure that our teams
and the people we work with and
ourselves even are really valuing the
smallest of details
yeah i do i do believe in
publishing
whether it's you want to call it an
ethos a manifesto
a set of principles
where you clearly articulate
what your
design standards are or your creative
standards
i've always believed that and they they
can change over time but i'm a big
believer in publishing
um thought publishing
ideals that that you have and i'll go
even further um because what i learned
over the years is is i was doing a
little bit too much self authorship when
i really started to manage teams i'd go
away
and i'd come back and it's like here's
the the six principles of of you know
obsessing the details that we're going
to focus on this year but i didn't
involve them in authoring those so it's
like
publish what you believe
invite
folks into the process that have
maybe slightly different opinions than
you do
and then complete this build the
consensus and then make sure everyone
has it so that clearly as you drive down
the road and you're looking at
restaurant architecture
you know business
building architecture it's pretty clear
that people just decided like it was
good enough and
no one will ever you know who cares if
it's going to win the point isn't to win
awards the point is take something as
far as you can
um
to
contribute something great to
you know to society whether it is a
building
or um
a book or this bottle design um you know
the amount of thought that went into
that i think that's the typeface
helvetica i believe and the choices made
to go upper and lower case like that's
all intentional
you know to have it black on white
um
human fuel yeah well and that's the
thing i mean you have to start with
naming right and one of the hardest
pursuits is naming a product or naming a
company because it's such a crowded
space but man if you get the name right
it will save you
millions in marketing
so if i was to ask you now and i used to
say right i have a team of 100 000
people and i want them to be great
marketeers but we're only allowed to
give them
three guiding principles
which they will take with them these can
just be philosophies ideas whatever but
we can only give them three guiding
principles to hope to make them
successful what would those top three
guiding principles be
i'll start with the three
characteristics
um that i would say it's like we're
gonna we're gonna have the dominant
traits of empathy curiosity
and let's call it courage or risk taking
like those
those three traits is what we're going
to be known for
and for empathy
you know to me within the marketing
process is is you know the principle
that i talk about in the book is you
know see what others see
find what others don't
the best marketing teams and the best
communication teams
are able to peel back the layers get
under the surface of a human being
a city or a community
and find the deeper
insight or truth
that resides there and then they reveal
it through storytelling it's back to the
michael jordan example how many how many
more
ads could you do about him dunking a
basketball so empathy is like go deeper
whether you're designing a product it's
like
you know you're you're
you're revealing the the the true
problem that needs to be solved you're
not just observing some behavior and
making
um you know uh a
you know hypothesis off that you're
actually spending the time to go deeper
and deeper into that and that's that
idea of see what others see find what
others don't curiosity is that idea of
getting outside yourself
because
it's one thing to have
the insight
right and the problem that you're going
to solve and you're clear on that
but now you need to reveal it to the
world
and oftentimes you need
uh points of inspiration coming into the
process and that's why
you look at
nike air
probably the greatest innovation in the
history of of sneakers right uh
air air
air bags and air cushioning and sneakers
well that came from an engineer at nasa
who was
experimenting with creating an
innovation for astronaut helmets for
space exploration
and he brought that to nike and that led
to nike air that's my point about find
inspiration outside of your sector and
that's the idea of bringing the outside
in so that's the curiosity thing outside
uh get outside yourself and then
you know
finally is that idea of of you know we
don't play it safe we play to win
um we want to def we we're not
comfortable with the status quo
um and
we want people comfortable
kind of
pursuing what's next
not just getting complacent and
delivering
products services
stories in the way everyone else is so
we also want to be a team that that is
obsessive about
um every aspect of
branding
you know and so
think of how powerful that can become is
if you have
a team
and that they're deeply empathetic to
who they serve like they get great at
learning and asking questions
they're unbelievable uh
unbelievably curious and always looking
beyond what's in front of them to see
what else they can because so much of
innovation is about transference you
take something from here you bring it
into your sector
and you you you change the game and then
and then but and then the risk-taking
thing is not feeling like you have a
team that has to ask for permission to
use their imagination i think that's
really important
because
if you're in a if you develop a culture
where
people have to ask
um to think people have to get approval
um
then you're not i i don't believe you
would be known as a leading innovator in
in your space on that so those are just
a few but i i just think it's also i'll
tell you this when i was cmo i did an
informal
poll with
my
the marketing leaders and i'm biased of
course but
i felt and i believe this is the best
marketing team in the world i said what
are the top two characteristics you look
for in any marketer that you're
interviewing for a particular job
within the nike marketing team and the
top two
um traits that
came to the top from everybody was
curiosity
and collaborative
i mean to a person and it was kind of
tied i want someone who's
always searching for inspiration is
curious about
about their teammates about the consumer
about technology entertainment
art
and then i want someone who who can play
with others right and um that you can
feel that sense that this person is um
has conviction um you know believes in
themselves but can play within a in a
team um and those were the two that that
rose to the top and and um you know and
i i think that's true today
quick one i just wanted to share a
fantastic initiative from one of my
podcast sponsors for those of you that
are looking to grow your business online
right now you can get 200 pounds of
social media advertising paid for by
vodafone business when you sign up to
three unlimited mobile plans social
media has a huge impact on your business
if i had to start my business again from
scratch right now the first thing i
would do is produce content daily at a
high cadence the thing that grew my
company so fast was producing content on
social media platforms it helps your
company become known and build your
digital reputation slash personal brand
if you've not ventured into the space of
social media or social media advertising
before don't worry vodafone business
will also provide the knowledge support
and tips you need in creating a plan all
through vodafone vhub to find out more
and how i'd spend that 200 pounds at
vodafone giving search vodafone digital
boost and obviously terms and conditions
apply
april 2021
significant month for you in your life
does it ring a bell yeah absolutely yes
i was sitting at home uh actually
reading the new york times an actual
newspaper remember those
um and uh yeah i got a a dm uh through
23andme i had i had done the 23andme
thing
23andme for anybody that doesn't yeah so
you you submit your dna um and it's
along with ancestry.com
um it gives you kind of your family tree
you can figure out others that have
joined 23andme if you're related to them
uh and um
you know a variety of other
things in terms of what you might be
susceptible for from a medical
standpoint or other
and so
you know as some as an adoptee and
growing up not knowing who my parents
were or who my families were
having lots of questions my whole life
but basically i'd gotten to the point
where it is what it is and i'm just
moving on with my life right
um so i'm sitting around and i get this
this dm and and through 23andme and and
i usually just ignore those because
sometimes it's like hey you have a uh
predisposition to like uh breadcrust i
mean you get these emails right and it's
like oh and great another 23andme notice
but i look in it and this note says um
wow i had no idea i had an uncle
on this uh
or in life
and so i looked at it and then um i
looked at the name and i went to
you know as you do i went to facebook
right and i looked this person up
and i was like whoa so the person went
to my high school
the person was also a graphic designer
which was my what i got a degree in they
had a degree
and as we did my wife and i did a little
bit more sleuthing it turned out that
this wasn't my niece this was my
sister
and this meant that
her mom was
you know not my sister her mom was my
mom
and so
wow that that was a lot right and that
opened up uh an unbelievable door
over the last year of meeting my birth
families
and for the first time being able to
answer questions like why do i look the
way i do
why do i have this
why is my voice the way it is and why do
i have certain characteristics or
passions and as i dove deeper into it um
you know two things started to unfold
one is the the amount of art and design
um practice going back generations on
both sides right not to mention my
sister
you know as a graphic designer my birth
mom was a long time flight attendant but
would spend all of her down time at art
museums from around the world
my birth grandmother was a painter right
and there was art and design on my
father's side
but
kind of going back to where we started
this conversation right about race and
search for identity
and not necessarily growing up
with the black experience at least the
positive one
and to come all the way to today and
have spent the last year
diving very deep into my
african-american heritage
going all the way back pre-civil
american civil war
and um
and just i i i can't tell you what a
life bonus this has been um i can't put
a dollar amount
on it to be able to
start to
put the pieces together
for the first time
because up until now you're you're
manufacturing a lot of that as someone
who's
who's adopted right um
and um so yeah it's just uh it's it's
just been an amazing run they don't all
you know reuniting with birth families
doesn't you know the percentages aren't
always high that is going to be a
positive one and in this case
um everyone has been just i mean
unbelievably
generous with their time thoughtful
and
i have
i could put together a museum of all the
objects and
pictures and um
memorabilia from
the generations of these families um you
know now and it's just been uh it's just
been amazing and i wanted to make sure i
i captured some of that in the book
to
to honor
them as well and i want to say something
too it's like
to learn that your grandfather was the
only black man
in his graduating class in college in
1955.
can you imagine what that was like
in america in 1955
to be the
only
black person let alone there was no
women in that class
so um yeah i i just look at that and uh
i i start to feel where some of my
um
drive uh to to you know
create things that stand out um do
things a bit differently
and um
and now i have a backstop if you will
um a history that maybe i didn't uh get
to draw from
uh in the past
you must have
first met
your and got to hug your biological
mother what was that day like
yeah i mean it it's again you're you're
talking about a time when you know my
birth parents were 17 when they had me
and
you know you've got two kids one's black
one one's white
in minnesota
in 1970
that's just not acceptable
you can imagine right
in high school
so
and
my birth mom right had to go live in a
home as you did as a teenager if you got
pregnant and to have me and then had to
give me up okay
so and then keeps that a secret
her whole life until
that day when her daughter said
i have to ask you something you know
i i know i have a brother
so
two months later
after lots of discussions kind of
getting comfortable getting to know i we
fly out there
and yeah i mean it's um as you're
i'm trying to play it cool because
that's me just always trying to be be um
you know
cool about things
and um but really it's it's just like
how's this gonna go i mean because the
last thing you want to be is rejected
but now that you've crossed that point
there's
you this is a new experience that you
know you've never had
so what's great that my birth mom did is
i i as we parked and we met like
at a park acro on a lake with with them
is she just cause
i didn't know if i could make the first
move but she came running up and just
gave me a big hug we didn't even say
anything and that was the beginning of
that the first time i saw her in person
and it was just uh
yeah i mean um
you know uh
it's just i'll be honest i'm a happier
person
so
you know
and
it's not that i was i i've gotten so
much
so much i have such a wonderful family
and kids
and such an amazing career and having
the opportunity to share it with
everybody um but to experience this at
this stage of my life is just i mean
it's just amazing
thank you
it's been a real honor and uh you know
you you've inspired me tremendously for
so many reasons and you've been a real
sort of affirming
uh and reaffirming force reading your
book emotion by design um
has taught me a lot of the things that i
did right and i didn't even know i did
write and then a lot of the things that
i definitely could have done better in
certain areas of my life and even you
know i can say i'm
almost 30 years old as a marketeer
but you've illuminated certain things
that i i don't think people talk about
enough especially considering the way
that the world is heading and it's and
how you know creativity is being
sometimes talked about in a secondary
sense to things like ai and data and and
we're losing the human in things but not
just in marketing in the world as well
there's an optimization of our lives
driven by data which is which is
sacrificing the love and the art and the
beauty of what it is to be a human and
that's also the broader point that i got
from the book is and from you today is
is the importance of not losing that and
yeah we do have a closing tradition on
this podcast
which is the previous guest leaves a
question for the next guest
is there something right now
that you know you're doing wrong
but you haven't fixed yet
if so
how will you get
unstuck wow
now we're going deep
the election
in america
um in 2016
really
damaged the relationship with my parents
my
parents who adopted me
because i'm you know
uh obviously being um
you can see through the work that i'm
very much um
you know on the left if someone wanted
to uh
you know categorize me as such and i
think you could cater categorize my
parents maybe on the right and
just through all the um
uh
just the divisiveness of
america and
the
division between political parties as
well as um
you know the citizens of america
unfortunately that is where
uh my own
family went right because
um i don't share those values and so
it's not
right right now um and i'm not one to to
allow something to just
you know not be fixed so
while i don't have the answers to that i
can say and i'm revealing maybe too much
about my life because on the one hand
i've met my birth families and i have
these two new families i'm
really enjoying and engaging with
and then on the other side i need to
figure out
how to get beyond the politics
um
that exists today back to this idea of
getting past the ideology
to have
you know to go back to why we're
connected in the first place through
emotion
you know
um and so i'm gonna see everybody uh in
another month and um just try to create
a create a different type of um
you know
relationship um that is respectful on
both sides
so
um i don't know if that fully answers
the question you have it perfectly but
it's uh it's a hell of a thing what's
happened um
you know over over the last four or five
years and
how um it's it's
what started within politics um just
kind of moved into families and in some
cases it's broken them up
over um
you know
political views and such so it's less
about me being right or others being
right it's just trying to find like what
is the common kind of
you know cause that we can kind of
at least agree on
on that
so
perfectly answered and very very very
important topic that people don't talk
about enough because it i think a lot of
families will relate to that division
especially generationally right so kids
and their parents don't tend to be part
of the same
left right
values uh and i guess there's empathy
needed because
someone said to me one day which i've
never forgotten which is if you were if
you were them
you would be making the decisions and
believe what they believed and it's a
really simple concept but that strikes
empathy into me so i've had like a bit
of a falling out with my mom lately
and it's because of some you know in my
view it's the way she behaves in it
whatever um and and just coming back to
that point of like well if i was my mom
and i'd been born in nigeria and i'd had
the experiences of racism that she had
growing up and then moving to the uk
being the only black woman in a village
called plymouth in the uk
having your car burned and all of these
the things that have made her so bitter
if i if i was her i would be doing
exactly what she's doing even and her
son doesn't like what she's doing but if
i was her and i'd had her brain her
genetics her experiences i would be
doing the same thing
and for me that kind of has created an
empathy which allows me to try and keep
building the bridge
in you know an extended branch so yeah
you make a great point and i and i think
like you i never wanted i would see i
would hear about these estranged
relationships where people didn't talk
family members for years and i was like
well that's never going to be me
um but you can fall into it especially
when there's uh in in the
there's there's polarizing things
happening in the world to your point
where there's there's um there's bound
to be generational differences in terms
of you know the eyes you look through so
um but um that's also good advice that
that you have there it does get back to
empathy and practicing what i preach
thank you greg thank you appreciate it
as you might know crafted one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewellery and this
piece by crafted when i put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is
sometimes a little bit aggressive with
my goals and determined and courageous
and brave the really wonderful thing
about crafty jewelry is it's super
affordable it looks amazing the pieces
hold tremendous meaning and they are
really well made
uh
[Music]
you